انا اول حاجه المغرب هذه الطاقيه هذه
الطاقيه بالمنطقتكم المنطقه لشمال المغرب
من الريف هذه جبته انا اقسم بالله العظيم
طلعت في حوالي خمس ست قنوات هذه الخير
والله العظيم فيها الخير تعرف
بطولتين هذه بطوله المغرب اثنين بطوله
اثنين وشركه مع مع الفريق المحلي
دوحه العرب اللي الحمد لله لم يعد شمل
العرب واشكر جمهور المغربي اللي حج بكثافه
لهذه الارض المباركه وبهذه الترحاب بهذه
الاجواء ما شاء الله لان صراحه الجمهور
المغربي ما نقولك انقذ المونديال بس اعطى
صوره حضاريه حلوه كثير كثير كثير على
العرب كلهم وانا صور ثاني يوتيوبر فلوجر
صورت كل الجنسياتهم اقسم بالله كل جنسيات
العربيه كانت حاضره من المحيط الى الخليج
تحيه لكم كلكم نحبكم والحمد لله من المغرب
الجزائر تونس ليبيا مصر
والخليج كله عرب نحبكم كثير وان شاء الله
الفرحه الفرحه الفرحه تدوم والروح والروح
ماتش ماتش ماتش شباب اه نكون عن عقليه
الفائز عقليه الرابح ان شاء الله